[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry i hit the nos a little early
uh welcome to united's trailer
commentary for the fast and the furious
the first one i got lon here i got
danielle
uh we're family um and we're going to
talk about
all the fast and furious things that
went on
uh you know you know the drill we talk
about the film we'd give you our behind
the scenes thoughts
uh we're going to show you some deleted
scenes we'll respond to questions and
comments from viewers like you
and we will tease you with next week's
honest trailer
oh what a time capsule this film is this
really took
me back i uh you know fast
the fast franchise it's now some of the
biggest movies in the world
uh only outdone by uh end game and
infinity war as far as opening weekend
box office goes
uh but wow where it all began they're
around uh 10 minutes in they hit me with
a little
limp bizkit to ja rule crossfade and the
soundtrack
yeah oh yeah and i uh i dissociated and
and
entered my high school body um so what
what was uh
where were you in 2000
what was this uh when did this come out
2001 2001 i believe yeah i believe
i'll look it up but i think it's 2001.
more innocent time
that's for sure um and uh uh yeah what
are your feelings on this 2000
on where fast and furious began um you
know i hadn't seen this
in like a minute i was not prepared for
all the babes that love
cars whoo i was not prepared babes will
do
anything for cars did you guys know that
i mean
well we've all grown up well daniel
you've kind of moved around but we've
all
uh grown up in and around the southern
california area where this
this film takes place or at least lived
here for a very a very long time and um
uh i've never come upon a babe filled
street race
but i guess i'm just i guess i'm just
usually it's like if there's any car
thing going on
it's like a like a screen junkies video
men just
but man there are babes around we should
add it is not just like
this movie set in los angeles the first
one but the the
the fast and furious film universe
presupposes a world in which every major
city
every night of the week there is a place
you could find
where there's like a huge over-the-top
very coordinated street race going on
like it doesn't matter where they are
miami rio every city has its own
underground street racing slash babe
circuit where people get together you
know wearing very tiny shorts
and uh have street races it's a
universal literally every city has one
um and that but they do make a big to-do
out of like going back to los angeles
in like the the fifth or the sixth one
right
race wars he's gotta take letty back to
race wars
but race wars is clearly in like uh past
that's a southern california
yeah what are you guys gonna do for race
wars this year
it's like coachella it's where the whole
city clears out you're like what's going
on this weekend it was so easy to get in
for brunch like race
and where does dom toretto go for race
wars
he won't tell it's a secret yeah he
won't say i guess
he goes to ambiguity wars yeah
yeah this was uh uh this is crazy just
some fun facts that i looked up
as i was researching this uh this film
um
uh the part of brian o'connor
was initially offered to marshall
mathers eminem
can you imagine this i mean that would
have just like completely changed this
whole very different
yeah gotta wonder if he would have stuck
with the role as long
as paul walker did right like would we
still be would eminem be in
like fast five like another uh another
almost casting
um also another uh fellow baldman but uh
very different vibe timothy elephant was
gonna play
dom toretto what yeah until
until vin diesel got on board um
interesting i can see him being
bald and violent in the hitman movies if
you're if you want to see what that
would have looked like
uh some other stuff um that uh didn't
make it in that just found
interesting um letty was going to cheat
on dom
with uh with paul walker with brian uh
but but lenny was like
that letty would never do that and they
cut it from the script
but it does seem like they're going
through a very bad patch in their
relationship uh
during this movie yeah um
yeah and then finally uh uh jordana
brewster and michelle rodriguez uh
neither of them uh knew how to drive so
uh
i i was looking for for shots where it
looked like they didn't know what they
were doing but it's pretty simple you
just kind of hold onto the wheel
in this one they don't like she she's a
good driver but they don't really
establish her bona fides is like she's
as good as the rest of the team until
she comes back in
five yeah like five is where she's just
taking part in the heist and you're like
oh i guess
she's just part of it now she's mostly
making sandwiches
in the first yeah i was gonna say like
she's either making sandwiches and like
they do a lot of shots where she's like
up in her room like
like with like spiral notebooks out is
she supposed to be a high schooler
i i thought i thought this too but i
feel like there was an earlier version
of the script where it was dom's much
younger sister
sister yeah he's more like a like a
father figure
he's like raising her and then i feel
like they decided
let's cast older and they brought
jordana brewster in and they're just
like stuck with a few scenes where she's
just like they still have something
in my room clarissa explains it all
she's like working on her
homework and then there's uh i feel like
in this movie
she's not supposed to be in high school
i feel like there was an earlier version
we're made
oh glad that decision was made uh yeah
they weren't she's like everyone's
surrogate mom she's always just like
feeding and cleaning everybody
well she is always cleaning yeah you
need her as a contemporary because she
ends up
like it would just throw off the whole
the whole universe if she was not
aged up it would be weird all right well
let's dive in to be honest teenager
around
we're fast and furious one and see what
else we have to say
wait we haven't done this one already
you sure weird
yeah weird it is weird
before these movies were about secret
agents fighting space crime or whatever
damn they got a magnet plane return to
the nuts and bolts of the fast saga
stealing dvd players is that a panasonic
pvm 939
sick they're gonna make like a hundred
bucks
yeah just that the macguffin at the
center of this movie is like
trucks full of dvd players is so funny
to me and then the other thing that they
keep mentioning
is like the fbi is really on this like
they're really worried about this
because the truckers are going to start
fighting back
half the truckers are going to take
matters which they do they do
in this film yeah that's already
happening silly
for them to be like like what if
long-haul truckers had guns
i think we live in a world in which
people who truck for a living probably
are armed uh
fairly safe assumption i don't know uh
but yeah like this is where the fb
the fbi like can't take it that like
people have been robbing trucks and the
reads the reason they're so concerned is
that truckers might
might shoot somebody that's trying to
rob them um
it's just in a movie not too many
truckers but with a setup like this
you've got to get like okay we need the
movie we want to make it about street
racing but we need to make the guy an
undercover cop that's the plot so you
have to figure out
why an undercover cop would need to also
be a good street ranger
the goal would be do it as like cleanly
and simply as you can
so it doesn't seem super dumb and
outrageous and
they did they didn't do a very good job
like it's it seems i think they're
outrageous they did but you're you're
coming for the wrong starting point
because the starting point was
okay point break they rob banks but we
need something
car related so what can they say what's
like a bank with wheels they should be
robbing
armored cars like with money in them
instead of
you just the whole the whole concept of
dvd players
the whole concept that they're not just
like you wouldn't need street racers
because you just get the guys to pull
over
you just like that you don't the only
reason you need street racers if you're
going to do the hijacking while
everybody's speeding down the road and
that's just like obviously
wrong like don't do it that way but it's
it's it's cinematic and
it's cinematic but like good fellas was
in like the 50s and they figured out
no no you pull a gun on the guy and then
he pulls over and then you rob
him while he's stopped you don't need to
play street race keep playing this movie
the one with all the thugs in it
remember point break well some
screenwriter did and figured if they
changed all the surfboards into toyotas
no one would notice
same location now the franchise that
would one day become the mcu with a ged
goes back to its humble roots as an
educational series about car parts
i lengthen the injected pulse it's your
fuel mac it's got a nasty hole
see a cooler intake and a t4 turbo
dominic
you see an aic controller direct port
granny fishing not double clutching like
you should now me and the mad scientist
got to rip apart the block
and replace the piston rings
i mean that was the second impetus for
this movie is like
somebody must have read an article about
street racing or something and it's like
this movie was a subculture film
in the same way that like breaking two
was about like oh the kids are doing
break dancing now let's make a movie
about
it and man if they dropped that thread
uh from this franchise but this one is
very very much
about cars and like your enjoyment of
this movie depends on whether you
think cars are cool or not because
there's just so much car stuff
what'd you say danielle and i take the
bus so
when is there going to be the movie for
bus drivers like this where they're all
standing around like oh i see you got uh
eight wheels on this bad boy
yeah perfectly this is perfectly time
for me because i was i don't know 14
15. like i was about to get a car when
this came out and like it
it just changed my whole understanding
of like okay well then if i get a civic
uh then i can save up and put like a new
like put a spoiler on it or put like uh
put like change the engine on it somehow
like
never happened um but get some nos get
some nos in there yeah gotta get that
nos
gotta get that ass uh yeah no it was f i
believe it was four when they
they made the explicit decision like
okay
international heist instead of car stuff
like let's let's
move it away from the gear heads and
make it more easier to sell overseas
broader more mainstream and uh wow it
worked but yeah it means the movies
don't have these scenes in them anymore
yeah it's jarring to see this be so much
about
um the pieces that make your car go
faster yes
now you get one seat where they go into
like a warehouse full of exotic cars and
they go like
you can have any car you want right and
then that's it now now it's back to the
height
all right keep going intercoolers ball
bearing turbos
and titanium valve springs look buddy
i'm not here to read the manual can you
make my sign look like an angry robot
penis or not
witness the birth of the movies that
have always been about family
even though half the original cast has
been disowned way to turn down half a
meal for the sequel jaw
cuda shooter luda but the keepers
i mean ja rule wow what a what a story
not the worst business decision he's
ever made but the second
time but he wouldn't have if he was
still in the fast and furious films
wouldn't have even gotten into that
whole
fire debacle that's right yeah
you'd have been put him on a totally
this would have put him on a totally
different path
uh and no we're not just being uh uh
cheeky
it that genuinely was the role ja rule's
role was literally given to
luda um so it really was a one-to-one
thing and yeah man he uh all he had to
do and this one was just like
st sit behind the wheel of a car and get
offered a threesome
and he's like that's too much work to do
it again no thanks
no thank you i don't he doesn't repeat
himself creatively i think that's what
it comes down to is like once john has
done a thing he needs to move on to the
next project you know
yeah and again it was um it was uh um
uh he just according to the producers he
just kind of ghosted them
like he just wasn't really responsive in
getting back to them for
the second one so yeah more ashante
songs
he had more yep just one busy man listen
going on yeah all right keep going but
the keepers were all there from the
start
like brian o'connor the most obvious cop
ever
look at this snowman right here man so
it's a good thing he's a stone cold
cutie pie
because when you're done i'm putting you
on the street where you belong cutie
he's beautiful i like his haircut he's
on a dangerous buzz
the other thing that i didn't put in
there but there's a definite like
uh intimate relationship there's sort of
a love triangle between dom vince and
brian
i feel like vince he of the he of the
multiple mesh tank tops is very
possessive
of dom's affection yeah i mean i don't
it doesn't necessarily need to be
homo erotic but like yeah it's it's
vince was
dom's like number one guy and now he's
being supplanted by this new guy and
there's a lot of tension there
i think you can read it as you know i
mean he kisses there's a
he kisses finn on his on his cute little
head
i mean listen a lot of this franchise is
just about
male love in its various forms i think
that's fair i think that's fair to say
yeah fair enough uh all right keep going
he's on a dangerous undercover mission
to infiltrate dominic toretto's sister
at the center of this early artie's
underworld
is human gravel mound vin diesel let's
go for a little ride
a star with such unique charms he's made
a side career out of playing barely
alive creatures who can only grant a
single word
but here he's dom toretto the ex-con who
runs a cool tank top club for wayward
youth
dom lives in his life a quarter mile at
a time because if he thought ahead any
longer he might wonder
wait why do i rob trucks at full speed
with harpoons
why don't i just make him pull over
first or should i drive for a living
given what happened to my dad
clipped his bumper and put him in the
wall 120.
i watched my dad burn to death or like
i've already stolen six million dollars
worth of dvd players
but i'll just retire and play with my
street sharks headshark
yeah pause i mean i guess it's thinking
too deeply about dom's motivation but
like if he's stolen and this is just
kind of a throwaway line from the fbi
but he's stolen
six million dollars worth of electronics
or trucks like
what's his end game like you don't need
six million dollars to like
retire in a pre-gentrified los angeles
flop house like what what's he need this
money for
i think he mentions it to letty
something about moving to a beach
just like that costs even less yeah
like what is his motivation for being a
thief like he kind of says like he's got
bills to pay but like
i feel like he could i don't know he
wins some street races or or sell some
sponsorships or something like that like
what's made him turn to crime in the
first place
uh i mean i i think there is also it's a
this is how he sees himself and like
this is how he
you know like he he otherwise what does
he do he's got all of these gifts and
all of these abilities
and yet he's just like hanging out in
this garage with his
pals all day i think this is a guy
banned from racing because he hit a guy
yeah with a wrench yeah like yeah he
didn't
he wasn't like uh born to be a criminal
he like
had this thing on his record and then
couldn't sort of just
go about getting a normal career and so
i think yeah he sort of sees himself as
like
well this is who i am and this is how i
define myself and like
yeah i think it's about running this
criminal empire as much as it is the
money
but that's truly i don't want to say
sociopathic but that's just like
messed up that you watch your dad burned
to death in like a
in a car race and you're like i'm going
to race cars for a living
a lot of people you know like i don't
know
that that doesn't strike me as like
impossible that that would happen yeah
yeah all right keep going return to a
pre-interview
where the only thing going on at
coachella was truck iced smile 114
outside coachella
that gathers every stereotype in the
city to race through la's trademark
traffic-free streets and shows off all
the candy-colored import cars
of a 15-year-old's dreams cause while a
ferrari is well out of your average
kid's reach
this film got every mouth breather to
put a new exhaust on their civic and
rear end someone because they were
playing snake on their nokia
i know i did i mean pause right there
like
dom is the only person who uh
got who gets in a car accident in this
entire movie and not to be like you know
old man like cranky dad over here but
like how many kids died because of these
films
like how many kids are like oh uh
car racing's a thing okay i'm gonna like
be i'm gonna put like a
an exhaust uh on my mazda and then
hit somebody probably like i i'll bet
this movie is responsible for more
deaths
than like the matrix or rambo or
something like that just putting that
out there
how many guests is rambo responsible for
i don't know
it's just yeah that doesn't make
violence glamorous at all
really 50 rambo deaths yeah yeah well
you're about three
you're like the first blood is like ooh
don't do that i'm sure someone
joined something you'll end up dying in
the woods
yeah rainbow the rainbow franchise okay
okay
i just think you know this is a street
racing movie where the only victims
are you know the people in the street
race it's not even they never run over
anybody
i don't even know that it's it makes
like freeway hijackings look
sexy but it definitely makes stuff like
race wars look cool and like this is a
huge party that you'd want to be into
like i'm sure it
it must have made street racing at least
temporarily more popular
yeah definitely i know it did for me um
well
i mean not for like you got into it as a
concept you didn't start actual street
racing did you
did you started missing i feel like
we're doing the anakin me
like wait did you you didn't really get
into street race
race wars i'm disappointed padme
alley all right keep going so after 20
years
nine movies and a universal studios ride
that made vin diesel the same size as a
helicopter
when the franchise wasn't trying to
outstun tom cruise the cast could all be
in the same room together
and all anyone cared about was finding
new and exciting ways to say
nos i need nos it's got a nice fogger
system it's got an obnoxious
blonde cellphone you're lucky that 100
shot of nos didn't blow the welds on the
intake
he ordered three t-66 turbos
with nos
i definitely should have put his words
yeah we should have put in the scene
from a
black sheep where the nitrous oxide's
leaking
[Laughter]
it's one of those weird words
all right keep going wing car puns as is
tradition
baby driver gran turetto kia
hot rodriguez carlos antenna
jesse pinkslip johnny transmission
ja rule presents tire festival and hello
spoilers car wars
rise of paul walker
have they just not ironed out the
details of their corona deal yet or what
yeah so yeah if you look at all the fast
and furious ones we've done i think
we've made all of them into
car wars like start different star wars
uh puns
and pretty much all the starrings have
been car puns and then i
i'm particularly proud that we kept it
going with hobbs and shaw
which is a spin-off and then we called
it brolo a car war story
to continue the analogy nicely done yeah
yeah so that's a little that's a little
nicely done us
backpack backpack where's the show about
we're so good at this yeah
um i don't have the script open but i
imagine this is uh
you have some questions and comments so
let's roll some deleted scenes
if we have any while i get that open
sister
and he must be good cause damn she drops
a dime in her own brother after one fast
and furious night of passion
what's the cell phone number 555-6439
starring the following car pawns greasy
lightning
yep that's it not much of the cutting
room floor
yeah yeah that deletes you know did
remind me of like
there's way more to put in for um paul
walker being an obvious cop because like
every conversation he has with mia or
dom or anyone is really like
so what do you guys do like for
criminals because
yeah where do you guys go at night what
are you doing what are you doing let me
in on all of your criming yeah
yeah he never even has like a convincing
backstory for like what are you doing
here
like how did you even hear about this
place like why did you show up every day
for a sandwich like he's so persistent
and then really never explains himself
no
they get he has a job like delivering
car parts
that's like his in and they make no
further questions about it
in fact dom actually dom tries to get
him cancelled
tom tries to cancel him he's like i'm
going to ruin your reputation around
this town like calls his boss and stuff
like that yeah
all right uh please uh subscribe and
like and thumbs up and all that stuff
because uh you know what that does it
makes you watch
uh these videos again when we do them
and that's every tuesday so
if you like them do that and now on to
your questions
um evan j pretzel writes uh universal's
mused about crossing this over with
jurassic park
what franchise would be amazing and
insane to mix in with the fast and
furious he suggests fast and furious and
the terminators
oh man not necessarily
one that is applicable like any from the
world
not not just stuff that they universal
owns right we're doing any
uh well yeah anything there's no rules
yeah yeah i'm going men in black
black yeah get them in with some aliens
i want to see
what kind of alien car they drive some
kind of space race yeah
see a space race get them up in there
even more than they already are i think
that that would be mine i mean i'm just
going to go ahead and
straight up mcu just like they're there
we got the we got the guardians you know
we've got the avengers
now we we've just got the the family
like the toretto clan
and they're just like they have their
own side adventures but then team up
movies it's like
yeah well if we're in a multiverse of
madness anyway who's to say
that you know dom and tej aren't there i
would definitely like to see
it's more of like like they get
subcontracted by shield to take out yeah
i don't know
yeah ant-man um sure yeah
yeah uh that'd be great um
well nobody said anything about they
have they're gonna have infinity stones
[Laughter]
through a portal you know yeah that's
pretty solid yeah um
i'll just go with cars you know but uh
but it's it
but it's live action um so there's just
now talking cars that they get inside
uh lightning mcqueen like i like the
first time they like open the door and
try to get inside they're just like
oh god it's full of blood
adam holbert asks what does it say about
me that i haven't seen a single fast and
furious what can you say to convince me
to see one well
look there's our job i always say like
this is a pretty
as far as point break rip-offs go like
this is a great one this is um
this is a really solid like action
dumb uh extreme sports movie it's just
cars instead of surfing so
try the first one see if you like that
and if you don't
try the fifth one which is where they've
completely abandoned that and they're
like this is just an
action heist franchise um
obviously you're not in this for the
plot uh so don't have
lower your expectations there but rarely
action movies are so if you like one or
five
um proceed accordingly what do you guys
say what's your pitch for fast affairs
or sh if you're not in at this point
you're
you should just stay out yeah i think if
you're not in at this point
uh well no you know what go see the next
the next one because the next one's got
even more
like craziness they actually do go to
space um as you can see i'm really tied
into space today should have worn nasa
t-shirt
um yeah go see this next one for one
thing it's a movie in theaters and
that's fun
um and then yeah i enjoy uh tyreese in
space
uh i i think these are the fun of like
superhero type movies but without all
the mythology
and backstory and ongoing linking up to
everything like i like that world
building stuff but it's kind of
refreshing to have
they go out they do heist they do
superhero exploits and then
it all gets wrapped up and they're back
home drinking coronas at the end
ready for the next adventure like it's
got that it's got that
bond thing where it's a formula you know
what to expect and it always starts and
closes in the same place and
there's something that's i think very
comforting about that it's a broly james
bond you're right
it's more that than the mcu because they
don't really
uh oh yeah hurrying stuff but that you
don't really have to only
only the people like the characters keep
coming back and we expand the ensemble
which is great
but you know like they barely ever
mentioned
things that specifically happened before
like it's like a
no no more complicated than a soap opera
in those yeah
like it's got no memory now it's back
you know it's like that stuff
lust 21 right uh speaking of cars what's
your favorite movie car
favorite on-screen vehicle
um i really like batman's the
batmobile and batman returns a lot
that's a good batmobile yeah that's a
good batman those burton batmobiles were
were the best yeah i think uh i i was
i'm tempted to say the ecto one
like probably the defining movie car of
my youth would be the ghostbusters ride
yeah i had a win i'm gonna keep it in
the diesel verse
um i love uh vin diesel's car in
xxx which is similar to his to his dodge
charger but i believe it's a it's a
pontiac gto
dark purplish with like the thing coming
out of the hood
and uh man that's a that's a cool car um
but uh uh
yeah i don't really know much about cars
so
uh uh that probably sucks and and is uh
terrible i don't know
um here's something i do know about our
reynard city update channel s what would
vin diesel wine taste like
i feel like there's a lot of sediment in
it
you're getting you're getting a weird
little like grainy
bits of something sand in the bottom
definitely yeah like a lot of it's like
mostly grape skin
yeah just a little like at the end
you're like
you got a little there's something like
a little
grain a little sand in the bottom there
those are tenants that's the
tenants that's tenants love those
tenants and it's all gravel filled
gravel filtered
like right it's poured through a gravel
pile and then recollected and bottled
in an oil can by the way repurposed oil
can
uh they do say in this movie like he's
got oil in his veins or something like
that
so okay final question uh jason rudolph
asked what movie would become better
with nine unnecessary sequels
hmm uh well since you brought it up and
it's one of my favorite movies i'm going
with breaking
just every year there's a new they keep
breaking they keep breaking
uh you can see it uh evolution of
breaking over the point of the 80s i
think it could be great you could just
follow it through there's a rec center
in every city y'all
yeah or am i just now describing step up
i might just be just yeah i think
you are the yeah they've done step up 5d
yeah
whatever uh i just rewatched this
because it it's
it's popped up on netflix but i'm gonna
go with the streets of fire that 80s
walter hill movie
you guys ever seen streets of fire it is
a like rock
musical
no it's walter hill uh
like right after the warriors and it's
willem dafoe is a biker who kidnaps
diane lane who's a rock star
and rick moranis is her manager and then
michael pereira and amy madigan go on
like a quest through
tough new york 80s to go rescue her it's
ludicrous but uh yeah you could just
have the ongoing adventures of michael
perez tough guy soldier character
in a string of rock musicals going all
the way up to the present day and i'd be
fine i'm into that yeah
well i like uh i would i haven't seen
that but i would love to do the warriors
with nine sequels the fact that that's
not an annual
franchise it's like if if the warriors
had more
just like more of the gangs were also
just like bands
this would basically be that like it's
very much in that world
also spinning off from that i would
watch nine more scott pilgrims where
they just kept fighting different bands
in different parts of toronto for for
different reasons or wherever
also pivoted about home to foe nine more
lighthouses where it's just him
different actors in black and white
going crazy on an island together i'd be
into that
love it uh actually that's a good clue
for next week's honest trailer
um yeah yeah that's that's your clue
uh it's not the lighthouse but it's
close yeah i wish it was when are we
doing the lighthouse
yeah someday we would have done in the
oscars one but it got snubbed
shocking uh all right that's it for
today uh please watch the love it or
hate it
uh video that we also made about fast
and furious to help you decide this is
actually a perfect one
for uh who asked about that uh adam
holbert
yeah uh go check that out and see if it
uh pushes you in either direction of
whether to watch these or not
uh that's what it's for and danielle lon
thank you so much for joining me
we'll be back next week y'all already
got the clue we'll see you then bye
[Music]
you